not morning rounds there's no evidence
that coffee can lead to a longer life
two studies from the US and Europe
showed similar results the American
study found that people who drink one
cup of coffee a day have a 12% lower
risk of dying those who have two or
three cups have an 18% lower risk
or dr. Terra new rule is here to sort it
all out so this is from Starbucks but
the bottom line is because I always
heard they don't drink too much coffee
and this says what this says that our
daily ritual one of our biggest
environmental exposures may actually not
only be safe but protective this is
basically adding on to a mounting body
of evidence that suggests this the first
study was a European study very large
almost 500,000 individuals across 10
countries followed for 16 years and they
found that those who drank three cups or
more in men they decreased their death
by about 18% and women decreased death
by about 8% the second study took place
in America looked at different ethnic
and racial backgrounds Japanese
Americans Latino Americans African
Americans whites and they also found a
decrease in mortality so for those that
drank 1 to 3 cups as you mentioned a
decreased risk of dying from 12 to 18
percent and this was decreased dying
from heart disease cancers respiratory
disease strokes decaffeinated doesn't
matter so that's what was interesting
about this I think we all think it's the
caffeine but in fact they found similar
effects for both caffeinated and decaf
nated which tells us that there's
something else going on we know that
coffee has about a thousand biologically
active compounds in it things like
antioxidants or polyphenols vitamins
like b3 magnesium and minerals
anti-inflammatory compounds research
previously has shown that coffee can is
associated with a decreased risk of
things like Parkinson's disease liver
and uterine cancer type 2 diabetes and
in fact when they looked at the blood of
the individuals in the European study
they found improved markers improved
blood sugar improved HDL or good
cholesterol improved liver function and
lower inflammatory markers so my
question would be is anyway without even
drinking coffee you could take these
things that add all these benefits and
get them some other way well that's
possible charlie but I think you know
we're talking about coffee yeah we're
talking about the bean we're talking
about the seed of the plant and so
certainly if you were to prepare it in a
different way if you're talking about
the compounds that are within you but I
think this is such a healthy thing to do
yeah everybody do it whether you like
coffee or not certainly I mean you know
I think it's important always with this
research and we talked about this to
point out limitations of the study okay
so yes we're seeing this mounting body
of evidence but these are observational
studies they don't prove cause and
effect
they were self-reported so people have
to fill out a questionnaire saying how
much they drank that's can lead to
errors they also looked at either one
point in time of these questionnaires or
just a couple points in time obviously
your habits can change in addition you
have to rule out other confounding
factors so for instance did people who
were healthier tend to drink more coffee
and that's why we're seeing decrease
mortality do they have other behavioral
dietary or socio-economic factors that
played in so you know it's definitely
important we need more research the
researchers are quick to point out we're
not saying go out and start drink coffee
to drink coffee but certainly a moderate
coffee consumption about 3 to 5 cups per
day 400 milligrams of caffeine can be
part of a healthy lifestyle so don't
feel bad for drinkers your coffee yeah
what do you think Gail do you think you
may use your teeth I don't think it's
white strips yeah and it can affect your
breath some coffees Scott no no like
yeah go I got an answer for you yeah I'm
gonna stick with my white hot chocolate
does that do for you Tara that stuff is
good at Starbucks highly recommended I
love my coffee okay well congratulations
all your coffee I like it
thank you Karen thank you I don't keep
you living longer yes